let's now bring in a member of the House
Judiciary Committee Ron de santis he's a
Republican from Florida who joins us
from Naples tonight he's also run for
governor in the fine state of Florida
representative thanks for being here we
really appreciate it
so you you I know that your chairman
Goodlatte is not satisfied with the
speed or volume of what do J has
produced as a member of that committee
tonight where are we on their ability to
produce documents that you need to see
well they're dragging their feet and
they've been doing this for for a long
time not only with the Judiciary
Committee but as ed mentioned with Devon
Nunez on the Intel committee and here's
the thing Pete if you were the subject
of a Justice Department civil
enforcement action and they were asked
subpoenaing documents from you you would
not be able to get away with these
excuses if you were a private business
you'd have to produce this stuff and so
it doesn't work that the government has
a different set of rules so I think the
question is is as are we going to
actually put the might of our
institution behind these subpoenas and
enforce them because you remember when
the IRS was dragging its feet I mean we
held Lois Lerner and contempt didn't
follow through with that guys like me
tried to impeach the IRS commissioner
for stonewalling on the targeting
investigation John Koskinen
it didn't get through Congress and so we
have certain tools at our disposal we
can use the power of the purse we can
hold officials in contempt and
ultimately if there still were calso
trend we can impeach these civil
officers we have to be willing to do
that otherwise I think they're just
gonna try to run out the clock on a lot
of this stuff so you've got civil
officers but representative you've also
got you know representatives political
appointees in these departments
appointed by President Trump I actually
had the opportunity about an hour ago to
speak to a senior DOJ official involved
in these matters and they point out a
couple of things they said this is the
first week since they've doubled the
amount of agents so there they are
trying to put the pedal of the metal on
producing documents they also noted that
another thousand pages will be delivered
for your committee by Monday and that
they just sent a letter to debe Nunez
saying that they're going to accommodate
his request for other members outside
the committee to review the FISA
application so if more people can see
those five say applications and more
documents are being produced do you feel
like you could get to a place where DOJ
is acting in good faith there just
haven't had the resources to do it
here's why I'm Scott
took all of that I hope that that's
right and I hope that we the American
people get what they are entitled to but
remember what Nunez has been trying to
get he's been trying to get those
initial documents about how this whole
Russia collusion with Trump's campaign
narrative started from the FBI and they
won't give that to him that's not a
million documents I mean that's
something there's probably one piece of
paper that officially opened this
investigation he's been asking for that
for months and they will not produce it
so I hope they're turning over a new
leaf but I just got to say you know the
last six to eight months has been one of
continually frustrating Congress's
Pragathi answers and the America that
you point take us under the hood a
little bit because it seems like we here
at the last minute from DOJ we're not
gonna meet the deadline right right that
day that moment are you at least hearing
days weeks before hey hey guys this is
not a deadline we're gonna meet we're
working as hard as we can we want to
produce these documents we're doing so
is that communication happening or is it
truly mostly quiet and then you find out
that not gonna happen yet we need more
time I think it's mostly quiet I mean I
think that there are instances where
saying Nunez is engaged with Rosenstein
or Ray and good luck can do that but but
also it's important to point out I mean
you know sessions maybe wanting to do
the right thing some of these guys maybe
the people are actually on the ground
they're a part of the permanent
bureaucracy and they talked about that
kind of cute exchange where they're like
oh we're just going to redact this
almost joking about it and that type of
attitude I think makes it very difficult
to get this stuff done in a timely
fashion so your concern is is maybe is
not the rank and file necessary and
necessarily at the FBI of DOJ or maybe
not you know the Attorney General or
array or others who may be trying to
it's it's that middle layer that has the
ability to slow walk it or to throw
throw a wrench in the gears and stop the
process I mean it's just a deep state
accusation or is this a bureaucrat as
you or do you think there's something
they're really hiding well I just think
at the end of the day bureaucracies tend
to protect themselves that's just the
instinct of it you know you have a lot
of people there who are dealing with
this they were not appointed by Donald
Trump I mean they're kind of career
folks and so I think that's the instinct
TEKT the agency to withhold and not
produce as much and I'm not even saying
it's for a nefarious reason but I think
that's the instinct that we see time and
time again and so you know we have we've
we've uncovered so much already with so
many questions and I just think this
posture that they've taken doesn't suit
the interests of the American people at
all we need a full accounting of how all
of this stuff happened absolutely a part
of that full accounting is what the
Inspector General is doing at DOJ any
updates yet on when we might get a
report on the hope Michael Horowitz his
investigation which a lot of people
think is is gonna expose a great deal of
things behind the scenes well he started
in January 2017 we thought by the end of
the year that didn't happen then we said
Oh February that didn't happen then we
said March no now April so I don't know
I think we need to get it because here's
why I think it's important I think there
will be some some interesting stuff and
there important stuff but I think the
fate of people like Peter struck the
notoriously anti-trump agent that talked
about preventing Donald Trump from being
elected with an insurance policy Lisa
page his lover I think their fates are
tied to that IG report and I don't think
that the FBI or deep justice is going to
move to fire them until that report
comes in because they want that to be
the justification so a lot of my kids
they should say why are these people
still there sure I'd like to see them
moved out too but I think once that
report hits I think that could probably
be the factor that leads for them to be
terminated we have very interesting
moment indeed congressman Ron de santis
thanks for time to see me we appreciate
it